♪ ♪
>> Chris: AS THE DEBATE
INTENSIFIES ABOUT HOW LONG TO
CONTINUE THE CORONAVIRUS
LOCKDOWN IN THIS COUNTRY, WE
WANT TO BRING IN ONE OF THE
NATION’S TOP EXPERTS ON
INFECTIOUS DISEASE EPIDEMICS.
JOIN US FOR BALTIMORE,
DR. THOMAS INGLESBY, DIRECTOR OF
THE CENTER FOR HEALTH SECURITY
AT JOHNS HOPKINS UNIVERSITY.
DOCTOR, LET’S START WITH THE
ASTONISHING SPREAD AND 2,000
DEATHS.
WHAT DOES THAT TELL YOU ABOUT
THE NATURE OF THIS VIRUS AND
WHERE ARE WE IN THE COURSE, IN
THE SPREAD HERE IN THE
UNITED STATES?
>> Dr. Inglesby: WELL, IT
TELLS US THAT THIS VIRUS IS ABLE
TO SPREAD PRETTY EFFICIENTLY AND
QUICKLY.
WE’VE SEEN THAT AROUND THE WORLD
IN THE LAST FEW MONTHS AND WE
SHOULD EXPECT THAT TO KEEP
HAPPENING IN THE UNITED STATES.
I THINK UNFORTUNATELY WE ARE
STILL AT THE VERY BEGINNING OF
THIS OUTBREAK AND WE SHOULD
EXPECT THAT TO CONTINUE FOR SOME
TIME AND REALLY FOCUS ON SOCIAL
DISTANCING IS ONE OF OUR MAIN
INTERVENTIONS TO TRY AND SLOW IT
IT.
>> Chris: I WANT TO PICK UP ON
THAT BECAUSE I WANT TO ASK YOU
ABOUT PRESIDENT TRUMP’S EVOLVING
POLICY ON HOW TO HANDLE THE
VIRUS.
AS YOU KNOW, HIS INITIAL 15 DAYS
TO STOP THE SPREAD OF THE VIRUS
GUIDELINES RUN OUT TOMORROW, THE
15 DAYS AND TOMORROW AND HE IS
NOW TALKING ABOUT THE
POSSIBILITY AND CERTAIN -- WHAT
HE CALLS "LOW RISK" PARTS WHERE
THERE’S A LOW INCIDENCE OF THE
VIRUS, REOPENING THOSE AREAS BY
EASTER.
HERE HE IS THIS WEEK.
>> THERE ARE LARGE SECONDS OF
OUR COUNTRY, PROBABLY CAN GO
BACK MUCH SOONER THAN OTHER
SECTIONS.
>> Chris: WILL THAT WORK?
AND WHAT ABOUT THE PRESIDENT’S
DISCUSSING THE IDEA THAT YOU
COULD HAVE SOME AREAS OF THE
COUNTRY WHERE YOU COULD BEGIN TO
OPEN IN TWO WEEKS?
>> Dr. Inglesby: YET, AT THIS
POINT, WE ARE SEEING NUMBERS GO
UP AROUND THE COUNTRY PRETTY
CONSISTENTLY.
THERE ISN’T REALLY ANY PLACE IN
THE COUNTRY WHERE WE SEE NUMBERS
GO DOWN AND WE WOULDN’T EXPECT
TO HAVE HAD ENOUGH TIME FOR
SOCIAL DISTANCING TO CHANGE THE
NUMBERS, SO I DON’T THINK WE
HAVE HAD NEARLY ENOUGH TIME FOR
THESE MEASURES TO TAKE FULL
EFFECT.
I DO THINK IN THE FUTURE IT’S
POSSIBLE THAT PARTS OF THE
COUNTRY, ONCE THEY GET CONTROL
OF THIS VIRUS THAT MAY BE STATES
OR REGIONS COULD BEGIN TO RELAX
SOCIAL DISTANCING MEASURES A
LITTLE SOONER THAN OTHER PARTS
OF THE COUNTRY BUT AS LONG AS
THE NUMBERS CONTINUE TO GO UP AS
THEY ARE AROUND THE COUNTRY I
THINK WE REALLY NEED TO HOLD
STEADY WITH THE SOCIAL
DISTANCING UNTIL WE HAVE A
NUMBER OF DIFFERENT CONDITIONS
IN PLACE.
>> Chris: I WANT TO PUT UP A
MAP BECAUSE IF YOU LOOK AT THE
SITUATION, THERE ARE BROAD PARTS
OF THE COUNTRY WHERE YOU CAN SEE
IN THE NORTHEAST, THE NEW YORK
GENERAL AREA, SOME CITIES, BIG
CITIES IN THE MIDWEST AND ON THE
WEST COAST WHERE THERE ARE
SERIOUS HOT SPOTS AND THEN THERE
ARE BROAD AREAS WHERE THERE ARE
VERY FEW CASES, SO WHY CAN’T WE,
AS THE PRESIDENT’S SUGGESTION,
TREAT DIFFERENT PARTS OF THE
COUNTRY WHERE THE VIRUS IS AT A
VERY DIFFERENT STAGE, TREAT
THOSE DIFFERENT PARTS OF THE
COUNTRY DIFFERENTLY?
>> Dr. Inglesby: I THINK THE
FIRST REASON IS THAT I DON’T
REALLY HAVE CONFIDENCE -- I
DON’T THINK MANY IN PUBLIC
HEALTH OF CONFIDENCE THAT WE
REALLY KNOW WHERE ALL THE CASES
ARE.
WE FIGURED TO DO MUCH MORE
DIAGNOSTIC TESTING AROUND THE
COUNTRY, ESPECIALLY IN PLACES
WHERE THERE IS A LOT OF ILLNESS.
BUT IN SOME PARTS OF THE COUNTRY
WE DON’T HAVE ENOUGH COVERAGE OF
DIAGNOSTIC TESTING.
WE ARE SEEING WHAT WE SEE, BUT
THERE COULD BE TWICE AS MANY,
THREE TIMES AS MANY, FOUR TIMES
AS MANY CASES IN A PARTICULAR
AREA OF THE COUNTRY THAT AREN’T
YET RECOGNIZED, SO WE NEED TO
GET TO A POINT IN THE COUNTRY
WHERE WE HAVE SUCH EXTENSIVE
DIAGNOSTIC TESTING THAT WE CAN
TEST PEOPLE WHO HAVE MILD
SYMPTOMS.
RIGHT NOW IN MANY PLACES IN THE
COUNTRY IF YOU HAVE MILD
SYMPTOMS YOU CAN’T GET A TEST,
BUT THOSE PEOPLE CAN SPREAD THE
DISEASE JUST AS WELL AS THE
PEOPLE WHO ARE SICK IN THE
HOSPITAL.
SO WE NEED TO GET TO A POINT --
GO AHEAD.
>> Chris: I DIDN’T MEAN TO
INTERRUPT, BUT THE PRESIDENT
TALKS ABOUT IN THESE CERTAIN
AREAS OF THE COUNTRY THE PEOPLE
COULD ACTUALLY GO BACK TO WORK,
GO BACK TO OFFICES AS LONG AS
THEY PRACTICE THE GUIDELINES FOR
THESE LAST 15 DAYS.
IN THE OFFICE, SOCIAL
DISTANCING, IN THE OFFICE GOOD
HYGIENE, WASHING YOUR HANDS A
LOT.
TAKE A LOOK AT WHAT THE
PRESIDENT SAID.
>> WE CAN SOCIALLY DISTANCE
OURSELVES AND GO TO WORK I DO
HAVE TO WORK A LITTLE BIT
HARDER.
YOU CAN CLEAN YOUR HANDS FIVE
TIMES MORE THAN YOU USED TO.
>> Chris: DOCTOR, WILL THAT
WORK?
>> Dr. Inglesby: I DON’T THINK
SO.
WE’VE SEEN IN ITALY FOR EXAMPLE,
WHICH IS A NUMBER OF WEEKS AHEAD
OF THE UNITED STATES IN TERMS OF
ITS EPIDEMIC THAT EVEN WITH VERY
SERIOUS, VERY AGGRESSIVE SOCIAL
DISTANCING MEASURES OR PEOPLE
HAVE BEEN KEPT AT HOME, SCHOOLS
HAVE BEEN CLOSED, EVERYONE IS
RECOMMENDED NOT TO LEAVE THEIR
HOMES THAT THIS DISEASE HAS
CONTINUED TO SPREAD AND IS
CAUSING NATIONAL CRISIS, SO AT
THIS POINT I THINK WHAT WE NEED
TO DO IS REALLY STICK WITH WHAT
OTHER COUNTRIES THAT HAVE HAD
MORE SUCCESS HAVE DONE, WHICH IS
THEY’VE LARGELY BEEN IN ASIA,
SINGAPORE, HONG KONG,
SOUTH KOREA, CHINA, TAIWAN.
THEY HAVE PUT IN PLACE SOCIAL
DISTANCING MEASURES UNTIL
THEY’VE GOTTEN CONTROL OF THE
EPIDEMIC CONVINCINGLY AND AT
THAT POINT BEGUN TO TRY
EXPERIMENTS WITH LOOSENING IT.
AND I DO THINK WE WILL GET TO
THAT POINT.
OBVIOUSLY WE NEED TO AS A
COUNTRY GET A POINT WHERE PEOPLE
CAN GO BACK TO WORK, BUT IF WE
GO BACK TO WORK TOO QUICKLY,
THIS EPIDEMIC IS GOING TO SPREAD
WIDELY AND AGGRESSIVELY AND WE
WON’T HAVE A NORMAL ECONOMY IN
THAT CASE ANYWAY.
SO I REALLY DO THINK THAT WHILE
THIS EPIDEMIC CONTINUES TO BE ON
THE RISE IN MANY PLACES IN THE
COUNTRY AND WE DON’T KNOW ENOUGH
ABOUT DIAGNOSTICS AND MANY OTHER
PARTS OF THE COUNTRY, WE REALLY
SHOULD HOLD THE COURSE.
>> Chris: SO, IF EASTER, AS
THE PRESIDENT HAS SUGGESTED IS
TOO SOON TO BEGIN TO LOOSEN THE
REINS IN THE LOW RISK AREAS,
WHEN WOULD YOU SAY -- THIS IS
THE KIND OF QUESTION REPORTERS
ASKED AND I’M SURE
EPIDEMIOLOGISTS LIKE YOU HATE MY
TWO QUESTIONS, ONE, WHAT IS THE
EARLIEST YOU THINK WE COULD
BEGIN TO LOOSEN THE REINS AND
SOME OF THE LESS AFFECTED AREAS
AND THE QUESTION I’M SURE
GETTING OVER AND OVER, HOW LONG
IS THIS GOING TO LAST BEFORE WE
REALLY GO BACK TO NORMAL?
>> Dr. Inglesby: SO I THINK
DATES ARE HARD TO PREDICT
BECAUSE EVERY DAY THE NUMBERS
CONTINUE TO GO UP IN MANY PARTS
OF THE COUNTRY.
I THINK WE SHOULD REALLY HAVE
THIS MORE LIKE A
CONDITIONS-BASED DECISION SO
WHEN WE SEE A STATE OR REGION
HAVE NUMBERS THAT GO DOWN OVER
TIME AND WHEN WE HAVE
DIAGNOSTICS IN PLACE AND WHEN WE
HAVE MASKS AVAILABLE FOR ALL OF
OUR DOCTORS AND NURSES FOR
PUTTING THEIR LIVES AT RISK TO
TAKE CARE OF SICK PATIENTS IN
HOSPITALS ARE WELL-PREPARED AND
WHEN WE CAN GET OUR PUBLIC
HEALTH SYSTEMS IN PLACE TO START
TRACING OR IDENTIFYING
INDIVIDUALS AND TRACING THEIR
CONTACTS AGAIN LIKE THEY DO IN
ASIA, I THINK THOSE FIVE NATURE
CONDITIONS, THEN I THINK IT’S A
TIME TO BEGIN TO THINK ABOUT HOW
WE MIGHT EXPERIMENT WITH
LIGHTENING SOCIAL DISTANCING’S
ONE STEP AT A TIME.
IT’S NOT CLEAR TO HIM HOW THAT’S
GOING TO HAPPEN.
WE’LL HAVE TO SEE WHERE WE ARE
IN TWO WEEKS.
IN OTHER COUNTRIES WHERE THEY
PUT SOCIAL DISTANCING MEASURES
IN PLACE AGGRESSIVELY IT’S TAKEN
ABOUT FOUR WEEKS FOR THOSE
MEASURES TO BEGIN TO HAVE AN
EFFECT.
BUT AT THAT POINT I THINK WE
COULD BEGIN TO LOOK FOR THE
CONDITIONS THAT MIGHT MAKE IT
SAFE TO BEGIN TO LOWER OUR
SOCIAL DISTANCING, BUT NOT UNTIL
THEN.
>> Chris: DOCTOR, THANK YOU.